welcome back I'm Steve Brenton and today
I'm gonna talk to you a bit more about
reinforcement learning so in the last
video I introduced the reinforcement
learning architecture how you can learn
to interact with a complex environment
from experience and today we're gonna
talk about deep reinforcement learning
or some of the really amazing advances
in this field that have been enabled by
deep neural networks and these advanced
computational architectures so again I
am I can Steve on Twitter please do
subscribe and do like do share this if
you find it useful and tell me other
things that you would like me to talk
about ok so again in the last video we
introduced this this agent the
environment the agent measures the
environment through this state s it
takes some action to interact with the
environment given by a policy so it has
a control policy based on how it acts
based on what state it's in and it is
optimizing this policy to maximize its
future rewards that it gets from the
environment and so mathematically this
policy is probabilistic so the agent has
some kind of some probabilistic strategy
for interacting with the environment
because the environment might be
stochastic or have some randomness to it
and there is a value function that tells
the agent how valuable being in a given
state is given the policy PI that it is
enacting and so today what we're going
to do is we're going to augment this
picture by introducing deep neural
networks for example to represent the
policy and so here we have now we've
replaced our policy with a deep neural
network so this PI is parametrized by
theta where theta describes this this
neural network and again it Maps the
current state to the best probabilistic
action to take in that environment and
so the whole name of the game is to
update this policy to maximize future
rewards and again we have this discount
rate gamma here that says that
rewards in the near future are worth
more than rewards in the distant future
okay because again remember these
rewards are gonna be relatively sparse
and infrequent most of the time because
we're in a semi supervised learning
framework where these rewards are only
occasional and so it's difficult to
figure out what actions actually gave
rise to those rewards this is gonna be a
pretty hard optimization problem to
learn this best policy of what actions
to take but you know and actually the
whole reinforcement learning paradigm is
biologically inspired it's it's
essentially inspired by this observation
so there's this this notion called
hebbian learning you may have heard this
before and the little rhyme goes neurons
that fire together wire together and
basically what that means is that when
you have neural activity
kind of when things fire together they
will essentially strengthen the wiring
and the connections between those
neurons and biological systems and so in
these kind of deep reinforcement
learning architectures the idea is that
the reward signal that you get
occasionally should somehow strengthen
connections that led to a good policy
when when the right policy is firing
when these neurons are connected in a
way that causes the policy the correct
policy and you get a reward you want to
somehow reinforce that architecture and
there's lots of ways of doing this
you know essentially through back
propagation and so on and so forth so
another area where a lot of research is
going into deep learning for
reinforcement learning is called cue
learning I talked about this in the last
video where this cue or quality function
essentially kind of combines the policy
and the value and it tells you jointly
how good is a current state given a
current action a-okay and so assuming
that I do the best possible thing for
all future states and actions so right
now if I find myself in state s an
action a I can assign a quality based on
the future value that I expect given
that state and given the best possible
policy I can cook up and
again there are deep queue networks
where you learn this quality function
and once you learn this quality function
then when you find yourself in a state s
you just look up the best possible a
that gives you the highest quality for
that state and this makes a lot of sense
this is a lot like how a person would
learn how to play chess is they would
kind of simultaneously be building a
policy of okay here's how I move in
these situations these are the trades
I'm willing to make and you're also
building a value function of how you
value different board positions and kind
of how you gauge your strength and the
strength of your position based on on
the state so it kind of makes sense that
this would be an area for really
expanding with deep neural networks
because these functions might be very
very complex functions of s and a and
that's exactly what neural networks are
good at is giving you very very complex
representing very complex functions if
you have enough training data so that's
what we're talking about here these
still suffer from all the same
challenges of regular reinforcement
learning like the credit assignment
problem so the fact that I might only
get our reward at the very end of my a
chess game makes it very hard to tell
which actions actually gave rise to that
award reward and so you're gonna do some
of the same things that you would
normally do like you might use reward
shaping to give intermediate rewards
based on some expert intuition or
guidance and there's lots of other
strategies like hindsight and replay and
things like that okay but the basic idea
is we're gonna take the same
reinforcement learning architecture and
we're going to either replace the policy
or the the cue function with a policy
network or a cue network good and all of
this kind of exploded on the scene
because of this 2015 nature paper human
level control through deep reinforcement
learning where these authors from deep
mine essentially showed that they could
build a reinforcement learner that could
beat human level performance in lots of
Atari classic Atari video games so I'm
gonna hit play I love this one this is
one of the first ones that got me really
excited about this so this
this this reinforcement learner is
essentially trying to maximize this
score by breaking all of these these
blocks and after a few hours of training
it has an epiphany that only really
excellent human players ever reach so it
essentially finds an exploit in the game
where it realizes that if it tunnels in
one side so it's going to tunnel through
here if it tunnels through one side it
can essentially use the physics of the
game to break all of these blocks for it
and that's pretty amazing so it in a
short amount of time learns a really
advanced strategy that only only a few
humans only a small percentage of humans
would actually learn eventually so
really impressive this is a beautiful
paper by the way you should should go
read this they talk about how they
actually build their networks so they
use the pixels of the screen itself as
the input and they use convolutional
layers and fully connected layers
eventually deciding what the joystick
should do what actions to take and a lot
like other examples and neural networks
this was the paper that really brought
reinforcement learning and deep
reinforcement learning back to
everyone's to the forefront of
everyone's mind because this showed
performance that hadn't been attainable
before so this is a lot like the image
net of reinforcement learning
okay this brought it back into the
forefront since then so Google bought
this company for half a billion dollars
because this was you know promised a big
step towards general artificial
intelligence or an artificial
intelligence system that could get good
at lots of things rather than just one
very specific task and since then
billions of dollars have been invested
into reinforcement learning in general
and deep reinforcement learning by it by
companies and so in this original paper
these are all of the Atari games that
they they try out and this is the level
above this they beat they're at or above
human level performance and there's only
a few games that they're below human
level performance and I actually think
it's pretty interesting to look through
these and figure out why why this this
deep mind was unable to figure out these
games but it was able to figure out
these games that's kind of an interest
interesting exercise actually I will
point out that the the algorithm in this
paper you could train it on one of these
games and it would get really really
good
but that same learned algorithm that
reinforcement learner cannot then be
used to play another game without
completely retraining it and so it's
still a way you know a ways away from
where we want to be we want to have a
learning system that can learn to play
all of these games and if it learns one
it can learn how to play the other
faster and better just like a human does
we're still a ways away from that but
tons of people are working on it it's
one of the big big problems in the field
is kind of transfer learning and general
artificial intelligence using
reinforcement learning so building a
learner that can learn lots of things
and learn faster from its experience
that's what humans do you get a kid you
teach them tic-tac-toe tic-tac-toe is
easy they learn the rules they learn how
to not lose then you give them checkers
checkers is a little bit more
sophisticated but they remember
everything they learn from tic-tac-toe
and they learn checkers faster again
they learn how to not lose then you give
them chess chess is a truly open-ended
game for most humans it takes a lifetime
to master and so based on what they know
from tic-tac-toe and checkers a child
will learn chess you know they can
transfer some of that over and then they
go into the real world and they learn
lots of other skills and those
problem-solving skills transfer over
that's what we eventually want with
computers we're not there yet but this
was a big step and I got everybody
really excited and still does good this
is another video I love this is from the
tech insider showing you know a lot of
these reinforcement learning algorithms
are used to train so this is google's
deepmind to train the reagent how to
walk or run or leap or swim or fly in an
artificial environment and that's pretty
amazing I mean this is a very complex
hard thing to do we take it for granted
our bodies are built to move very
efficiently and agile and accurate ways
but this is actually very challenging to
do and so the fact that these these
algorithms in a virtual environment can
learn how to run and walk and fly and
suin is really promising for robotic
technology so we eventually want to
learn how to do this in robotic systems
and make our robotic agents more
independent and more agile and that's
actually really hard that step from from
the artificial world to the real world
is challenging so for example to my
knowledge Boston Dynamics does not use a
ton of reinforcement learning they use a
lot of physics based modeling and kind
of by hand controls maybe they're
getting into reinforcement learning but
there's a long way to go to do this in
the real world it's still quite
impressive and this is a video I love so
this is training bipedal walkers
essentially generation after generation
of reinforcement learner and eventually
the the agent can learn kind of the
physics and learn the right control
policy in this case to walk forwards
stabili and you know keep its neck
straight and keep its legs straight and
I think this is just a really cool video
I'm in a nice demonstration I'll point
out there's some great resources other
resources on YouTube you should check
out for reinforcement learning I learned
about this in two minute papers which is
a great Channel I love love love
learning about things in two minute two
minutes papers
there's also archive insights has a
great series on reinforcement learning
and Brian Douglas has a nice kind of
reinforcement learning for control video
I believe it's in on math works okay
good so really impressive performance
just in the last ten years because of
these huge advances in the
representational power of neural
networks these can represent functions
that we didn't we previously couldn't
represent because they're extremely
expressive and we have lots more
training data we can train these because
our computers have gotten so much faster
and more powerful and there's also open
source software that makes it really
really easy to get started building
these neural network representations and
so if you have any interest at all in
modern reinforcement learning you have
to check out open AI Jim this is a
wonderful open source kind of
development framework where you can try
out your new reinforcement learning
algorithm on all of these different
systems both Atari games simulated you
know running and pendulum and really
cool physical systems that are hard to
control that are nonlinear you can get
started really quickly and easily in the
open AI gym and this is one of the big
reasons things are taking off so fast is
because there are these amazing open
resources for people to kind of try
things out quickly and rapidly prototype
and again you can try out all of these
Atari games and see if you can build a
reinforcement learner that can learn
multiple Atari games with the same
architecture that would be pretty
incredible ok and I also want to point
out these things are getting pretty
impressive so I almost everybody's heard
of alphago and how alphago beat the
human best go player in the world Lisa
doll doll from South Korea the the best
go player in the world was defeated by
alphago this was a deep reinforcement
learning algorithm developed at google
deepmind with the sole purpose of
learning how to play go okay and so I
want to point out that so reinforcement
learning is really good at learning the
rules of the game and how to win the
game when it's very constrained and when
it has all the time in the world to try
a millions or billions of different go
games so it's playing essentially with
itself getting better and better and
better
Lisa Dahl is a human and he has a life
and although he spends much of his time
in the NGO world he has a much much
richer broader world and he can go home
and he can go for a walk and he can
enjoy a sunset and so I I do want to
point out that and he can learn from
alphago and come back and be better the
next time and I think that's really also
quite impressive is that the human
masters learned from from from deep mind
and actually got better once they they
played up to their competition I think
that's really cool but anyway this
alphago learning system I think is
really interesting this deserves a whole
set of videos just to dive in I think
there
there's a documentary on this it's
really interesting so you should check
it out
the original alphago algorithm was based
on a convolutional neural network at CNN
and it had lots of reward shaping from
humans so expert humans guided the
reward structure for this alphago
learner so it didn't have to wait until
the end of the game to figure out if it
won or lost because that would take
forever
instead humans using reward shaping
helped it to get intermediate rewards to
help it to learn faster and give it a
denser reward structure now that's
tricky because if a human guides the
learning that almost caps out how good
it can possibly be because it's it's
fundamentally relying on human knowledge
so the next generation alphago zero
which came a couple of years later was
even better and much more impressive it
didn't use any human features no reward
shaping it only learned using self play
it just played itself until it became so
powerful that it could beat everyone in
the world including the original one and
it was based on a residual network
architecture kind of these that had
these you know jump connections and are
easier to train with with
backpropagation okay so really cool
advances and that actually was one of
the major advances that showed that
ResNet was you know kind of definitely a
major contender in the in the neural
network architecture scene okay so
anyway I think this is really cool it's
really interesting but again that is all
that this algorithm does in the world
and it doesn't know how to take what it
learned from go and do anything else
better and that's you know that's what
we need that's what we want in these
systems is to get really good at a game
and then take that and allow it you know
use that knowledge to get really good at
something else that's what we do and
that's really fun and you know that's
one of our strengths so some other
examples I love this is a video from
Stanford and from ETH Zurich where they
are essentially going to Train using
reinforcement learning flying on hat
aerial vehicles a helicopter and a
quadrotor so they can train these very
aggressive very high-performance
maneuvers using reinforcement learning
and so it is starting to happen that
we're going from these simulated
environments to the real world to real
robotic systems but it's very
challenging it takes you know a lot of
training and human guidance in general
and they're still limited examples of
real robotic reinforcement learning
actually someone asked me in my class
that I teach it at the University of
Washington what are some real examples
of reinforcement learning in industry
because a lot of you know a lot of times
you hear these game examples Atari or
alphago but I think actually one of the
original ones was in elevator scheduling
so it turns out and this is I would have
never thought but it's really
interesting it turns out that in a
really really big building like a super
skyscraper it has tons of elevators and
lots of floors scheduling these things
efficiently so that you don't get jammed
up and so that people can get where
they're going as fast as possible is a
huge problem
it's a combinatorially hard problem and
it's really hard to solve and
reinforcement learning was one of the
early algorithms that was used to kind
of figure out this near optimal
scheduling policy kind of interesting
good ok
so robotic learning is getting pretty
good okay so I just want to take a
couple of steps back and maybe summarize
so we've talked about reinforcement
learning in general both in the last
lecture and in this one as a kind of
framework for learning how to interact
with a complex environment based on your
experiences this is fundamentally
biologically inspired it's trying to
mimic how we learn how animals learn how
you train a dog and things like that and
in the last ten years because of
advances in deep neural network and
major advances in this architecture and
how we actually build and optimize these
reinforcement learners there have been
big steps towards more powerful more
general learning frameworks that can
learn how to interact with
more complex environments like beating
humans at alphago or actually moving you
know real robotic systems and it really
incredible ways but there's still a long
way to go so again I've said this a lot
I'm gonna keep stressing this we humans
have bodies and we are curious we go
explore and we touch and we learn and
you know children are curious and they
constantly are soaking up knowledge and
when they learn one thing they can use
it through this incredible human power
of abstraction they can use what they
learn in one scenario in a totally
different scenario that is still a
completely open problem in reinforcement
learning maybe not completely open it is
a pressing and central challenge in
modern reinforcement learning is how to
take what you learn and generalize how
to take a step back and use your
expertise in one problem in one
environment to solve another problem in
another environment that would be real
general artificial intelligence we're a
long way away from that so the good news
is that that's not going to be solved in
five years or ten years that's a
hundreds of year problem but it's really
exciting because that means you know
there's work to be done important
interesting work in the field of
reinforcement learning for you know
lifetimes of research to be done in
figuring out how to improve these
systems figuring out how to learn faster
and better both from from what you're
you're learning and the reward structure
of this problem but also from what
you've learned in other problems okay
thank you so much for watching